we are getting an inside look at a new
Netflix series based on a real life love
story you know we love that around here
from scratch it's inspired by the true
story of an actor and writer her name is
Tim B Locke and her late husband a
sicilian Chef named sorrow they met and
fell in I love this this song I love
this song They Met and fell in love with
Shelly while tembi was studying abroad
in Italy and it's based on her Memoir
published by Simon Schuster which by now
you know is like CBS is part of
Paramount Global so in the Memoir Tempe
writes about their big and beautiful
love adopting a daughter and the
obstacles that they face including
cancer we're sad to say that sorrow died
back in 2012. now Timmy and her sister
that's Attica are bringing their love
story to the big to the screen on
Netflix and while the names of the
characters have been changed the
challenges they face and their love is
real for real for real here's a look
I've never pictured my wedding without
my family
[Music]
there's people out there
they're my crazy family
and the people in Sicily are your crazy
family
the best
this is our family
just us right now going forward
just us
ing
[Music]
boy Timmy and Attica join us in the
studio it's good to see you both I'm
telling you people need to have a box of
tissues when they're watching this but
listen you're 20 years old Timmy you're
in Italy you're studying you're studying
abroad and you literally bump into it
what Sarah will call him in the movie
you literally just bump in Lino is what
he's calling the movie you literally
just bump him to them you bump into them
in the street did that really happen
that way I found that so hard to believe
I know so did I and I lived it yes I
bumped into him on the street I was
walking with a friend and we rounded a
corner and we you know just the way you
would a stranger you just brush
shoulders you bump into each other
she my friend happened to know him and
so they began a conversation I was
standing there I didn't speak Italian
really and so I just thought he's cute
uh-huh
um little did I know that meeting would
change the course of my life it really
did he is a chef yes and you all go
through it seemed to be difficulty on
both families that had trouble accepting
this relationship true yes absolutely my
in-laws were Sicilian Farmers from a
very small Mountain rural Town who the
idea of their son Marrying an American
first of all was beyond anything they
had conceived I wasn't I'm not Catholic
right
African-American and your dad's like he
does what he's a chef yeah exactly yeah
exactly a lot of obstacles it sounds
like a lot of obstacles and the and we
show in the series The Way parents
sometimes in their well-intended you
know sort of love for a child sometimes
can get in the way of what really was
supposed to laugh yeah what the heart
wants Attica why did you think that
timby should share this story with the
world I had a front row seat to one of
the most interesting stories I'd ever
seen the quality of love that they had
for each other the way in which they
chose to be fully present in life even
through life's biggest challenges even
with cancer they were so Fully Alive and
I thought this story about these East
Texans and these rural Sicilians
becoming over decades a family Beyond
language and borders and culture was too
riveting to not write down I just really
wanted her to write a book and I wanted
to write a book because I wanted to read
the book
let me just let me get a fact check on
one thing in particular here so uh so
she writes the book you wanted to read
it uh and then you pitched it through
Reese Witherspoon production company
without without coloring it with her
first I drew it is absolutely true I got
in their offices one day and they were
talking about interesting books and I
was like well you know I know an
interesting and I just pitched my
sister's entire book her life story and
for a second they were like your sister
wait a minute I don't know about all
this but they said yes they they were
curious and they said yes and re-spread
it and everyone in the office has read
it and they said within like a week we
were sitting there trying to figure out
how do we make this into a show and I
called her from the valet how did I
respond when you called I called her
from the valley and I was like don't be
mad
I may have pitched your entire book
never a good start with somebody I knew
I was like what has happened some of the
scenes were so personal I kept wondering
did that really happen like you guys had
a fight you and Lee know how to fight
and it's pouring rain and you're up in
your apartment and he comes he's walking
in the rain and you come running down
and you run to the rain and you hug each
other and you jump in his arms did that
really happen he stood in there and you
were wrong by the way
he was like you was out of pocket
listen I had a lot of growing to do he
inducted me into a love that was bigger
than what I could see did that really
happen though so yes he stood and waited
in the rain for me yes he waited in the
rain for me and I didn't run out and hug
in the street I was like get out of the
rain come upstairs come upstairs I don't
want to get my hair I don't want to get
my hair wet but um but yes it it that
moment happened and it was one of the
moments that I write about in the book
and it was a life-changing moment he's
diagnosed with cancer and you went
actually end up you're together for 10
years you were a caretaker we I'm glad
to say that you have found love again
and you were remarried and I was
wondering we were talking before you
came because your husband your husband
current husband says I think this is
good you're telling the story because it
gives me a template of your heart Nate
and Tony were like well I don't know how
I would feel no no I yeah I was being
honest and I thought you know does your
ex love
um still own a little bit of real estate
of your heart and your mind might that
be hard for your current how's your
current husband about that just an
honest answer from a couple of men that
are curious no married men no app
absolutely and to re-partner with
someone no it's a
it's a degree partner with someone after
loss means to
own all of who they are and that
includes their past and my love for my
late husband does not diminish because I
love my husband and the Heart can hold
both yeah
so much beautiful from scratch is
available now on Netflix
that is a great answer